so let's go with efore here maybe enter
as vesion akov let's see if well it's an
open society let me say that much now
they get to choose we're gonna have a
lot Dragon Knight orph okay let's go
with what let's go with this see what
they do okay now let us see about an
early g4 g5 might there be h5 here let's
try see what they do what will my
opponent do in response to this launch
of the Jeep on is h6 a good idea okay
let me see if I could get this in h4 +
g5 okay they're putting a clamp down on
that move hmm interesting let's try this
side of the board let's try this side of
the board looking to clamp down on b6
and also just stop b5 hmm pretty
interesting you don't see this quite a
bit
alright you don't see this often the
kingside absolutely close down here I
mean there's not going to be any f-pawn
brakes and I can be seeing f4 f5 unless
there's some crazy tactics we might have
the H file opening up other than that
I'm not so sure let me push forward some
more and yeah let's see eventual a 95
move might be on the cards clamping down
on this square because I might one day
want to get my knight there but I do
have to watch out for this prong maybe
it's a good idea to play f3
I wonder if my opponent has h5 available
at age five I might do age three I get
pretty nuts after that move so huh
that's pretty scary that move that is a
pretty scary move right there
hmm
Knight takes
wow this is gonna get real wild here
night pond takes Knight takes Knight a5
to watch over c4 this is a big concern
for me that is a big concern for me this
c4 square let's try this my knight from
a b3 wasn't doing anything anyway um I
really do want to get in this d5 move is
now available so this is gonna get nuts
quick it's gonna get nuts quick and now
this is this is something I'm definitely
gonna have to rethink because now guess
what I can't Castle kingside
my opponents still could so something
like Bishop e7 Castle although you know
that's not without its risks either huh
because of ih4 maybe and I could still
open things up ooh okay so now I could
take this Knight and then take here
hmmm this is gonna get nuts really
really nuts here Wow
pawn takes knight takes this guy is
starting to be out of play do I really
want to give up my dark square bishop
dish right here takes takes takes like
this takes takes and then this pawn
falls my dark squares are very weak this
is a strong move Wow
in trouble the center is collapsing here
hmm what could I do to weasel out of
this is there any weaseling Vaughn takes
Knight takes Knight takes pins the night
the night will end up hitting my bishop
huh well I'm gonna try it and in fact
I'm not gonna take here I try this
instead
there's Queen takes pawn here and then
it's on my knight but I want to somehow
be disruptive to my opponent maybe I
could be making use of this square at
some point it takes to give it a shot I
have to give this a shot I want to maybe
get this King and Castle this is my only
move Queen block my rook falls dark
squares are a problem but I guess my
opponent has some light square issues
this is wild this Knight is kind of out
of play it could take with check but I
think maybe just getting the bishop oh I
don't know if that was well let's see
let's see about that one what about
night here or no wait look here I have
this available let's get this moving
rook up and over okay so this is an
important one I think I have the better
development my king is I'd have to watch
for this diagonal but I can maybe get
back on it oh I'm seeing maybe get rid
of this Knight and then focus on this
square and now I have I could get here
maybe just this could I really get that
night
I'm gonna try this
now that's maybe a bit too far-fetched
maybe a bit too far-fetched as that move
now let's try it let's try it I'm trying
to focus on the light squares a Knight
takes pawn rook takes Bishop and then I
get the Knight Bishop here soon
you can then then pivot here Bishop d3
Queen to e2 Queen to e4 light square I'm
kind of focused on this oh no oh my pot
was disconnected but they just
reconnected so they just lost some time
technical issues on their end less than
a minute 10 tight game very wild very
very wild okay
I was just thinking about rook here
let's not do that
no way
bishop here pawn push Bishop takes pawn
takes Bishop takes rook Bishop takes
rook now then this Knight fouls okay
let's come over here
and then not quite sure
huh Wow we're pretty equal with time
this is very scary Knight takes pawn
maybe okay now I am running out of a
plan here whew
I got a play here I gotta watch this
pawn and also stop in castle haha
this is nuts a knight coming here maybe
Queen here maybe there's a queen trade
in the in the future b6 rook takes pawn
maybe wow wow wow I don't have any time
not anytime night here is gonna be
lethal isn't it uh oh oh I have this in
between check to guard the knight first
that was missed by my opponent I think
right am I missing something though how
much time do I have
Queen trade Queen trade
I want to do this the probably
unexpected and unexpected move and then
defend this rook in pond looking pond
position how much time where we got what
do we got what do we got I got this pond
I got this one I'm up a pond but time
time how much time time time oh man
good game that was absolutely crazy that
was a crazy one let me hit the replay
button on that one let's go back
my opponent treated it very well right
there in the center be aware of this
idea so some I some ideas to take away
from this game or how to treat this g4
g5 thing there's a difference there's a
there is a significant difference
between if I really do want to play this
g4 move and I at first of all I don't
know if it's correct but at this point
right here at least the difference
between rook g1 and H for you
one might think oh well don't play this
or this it doesn't really matter I think
it matters like a lot because if I play
rook g1 then there is this g5 move as
was played but if I play h4 well there
isn't this g5 move not so fast
if I do h4 and then rough g1 then I'm
threatening this push and the difference
between the two again is significant in
the sense that I could I am still
threatening to get in g5 and
and and and this is a very important one
I retain the option to maybe castle
although I probably wouldn't want a
Castle kingside because I am launching
these gah puns but I think first making
sure the age pun is advanced prior to
the rook playing to g1 so important
detail because now it's like okay forget
about the kingside immediately as soon
as g5 was played I'm like my attention
shifted to my left here I'm focused on
the Queen side I'm like okay what's
gonna go on over here what's gonna go on
in the center because the King side shut
down a for Queen c7 a 5 B 6 I think is a
very good move I think it's a very very
good should I have taken maybe I
shouldn't have because when that night
is on b6 this d5 move is coming it got
really nuts really really nuts so I
don't know but if there's something to
take away from it it's it's these
earlier ideas I was just expressing the
h4 and rook g1 the difference between
the two yeah I was I play again I played
the Knight a5 move because I was very
concerned about a knight being able to
sit here or something along the lines of
like bishop playing here getting these
bishops off the board and then had me
having to deal with the knight there
it's very strong Wow rook up rook over
oh man Wow Knight coming to f4 was very
scary what a game what a fantastic game
best one of this stream that's for sure
very exciting nice very very nice game
we were just going into blitz mode at
this point
right about time scramble okay
good game